all right brad yes sir brad
where are you where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm originally
from new york pennsylvania
pennsylvania and uh tell me about your
childhood how did you grow up
well i grew up kind of kind of crappy
i mean i had a good mom but not a dad
dad was drunk
um he would beat on us rape us
um beat on my mom then
like my mom was a cna so like she was a
good worker you know i mean so like uh
it didn't matter whatever we did like he
would child tell us not to tell our moms
and stuff but uh my mom didn't want to
believe us anyway
so life hood was shitty
i mean so now i'm trying now what kind
of stuff are you going through
i'm going through a lot of depression
anxiety like times
what kind of stuff are you going through
any sexual abuse sexual abuse yes
all that when did that start huh when
did that happen when i was six years old
six or seven and it happened it didn't
stop till i was about 10 or 11. who was
who's doing that to you to my father
your dad yeah
so then i decided one time i just took a
baseball bat and started beating on my
father so
and uh there was blood everywhere so
somebody called the cops and they put me
in a foster room so they took me away
from my mom and uh
i tried killing myself at age 11 so
i thought i was taking knives i was
cutting my wrist um
i wanted to die you know what i mean so
like nobody wants to accept me so
childhood was rough you know i mean and
then i started becoming 12.
i started smoking pot i mean then i
started
messing with like all these [ __ ]
gangs and like
department language but i wanted to sell
drugs sell guns you know i mean like be
with like cartel type
material i mean like i'm a big boy i was
a big boy all my life you know i mean so
like
i thought i could run things you know i
mean then i was bullied and then
i started getting beat on and i started
beating on people and
i started robbing [ __ ] and then uh
then 15 16.
uh i got out foster went back to my mom
then um
she had a new boyfriend he treated like
[ __ ] and then used to beat on us you
know because we didn't do something
right away so
the one day we went to atlantic city and
you know because i wouldn't take my hat
off
he decided to push me over the bed and
make me smack my head off the ac
to like bust my head at him so my papi
got mad and like three pieced him
and then busted his lip and then my mom
was mad
and then it's just a whole life story
that i came 18
i had a woman and then we had kids
together
and four years later
she was killed by a drunk driver with my
kids
so like i've been through depression my
head's messed up from that
and then my grandma died like a couple
years after that
so you lost your kids and your yes my
first baby mom
my second baby mom just died like three
four days ago
maybe five days a good part yeah i think
about five
and then i was on my way up to
california um i was homeless
trying to find a spot up here my brother
lives at laghini beach so
um he's a rapper and uh
for for youtube he's on youtube as well
so
everybody that says his name is his name
is uh ross cling
so everybody knows ross cling um
that's my brother but i'm trying to get
get to him i mean so
you've been you've been down here on
schedule how long um i just came here
two days now or that today since last
night i've been walking around the
streets trying to find us where the cops
keep
running me off the streets um so i don't
know what else to do i've got my money
token i got
my my phone like i can't make any phone
calls
like welcome to schedule huh what
brought me um
no i said welcome to schedule welcome
well thank you
so like what's uh so what's what's your
drug
um i do like meth molly crack
uh coat soft like weed just i don't do
like
fatty and like heroin i don't do that
but uh
i don't do drugs all the time just i
smoke weed all the time during the life
but
i have i've been kind of sober for a
couple days now actually so
you say you have a drug problem or
addiction or you uh um
it's a thing that i can do it and i can
stop it
like i can do it all day every day and i
can stop it like cold turkey
like it's weird but it's not weird you
know i mean
so i'm trying to figure that out you
know i mean so
my life is complicated right now i mean
i can't i don't want to do like since
i'm homeless here
i wouldn't be homeless if i can get down
to there but
you know i mean so yeah i have people
that
give me like like food here and there
but they brought me down here because
they said there's free food and stuff
and free tents and
i ain't trying to get all that once i
try to get a job or something or make a
couple dollars i can get on an amtrak
which is like
60 bucks or 100 bucks only that i can go
right to the beach i need to go
to get to my brother the problem is i
don't have an address
so once i go there i got at least sleep
on the street again for a half day a day
or maybe walk around and i might run
into them so
i don't know i mean so my life has
messed up
and i don't ask nobody for help i've
never asked anybody for help and i've
always done for myself
i either i used to rob people or just
take it
or people used to help me out and like i
appreciate things
but sometimes i feel like they feel like
i'm not appreciative right
so i i kind of want to help people and i
mean like i want to help kids i want to
help people
i want to help i don't know i want to
help battered women
you know i mean people that have been
like sexually abused and all that stuff
that's not cool
like i mean why people are on that kind
of level i don't know like we all should
stick together like we're all
family i mean so do you feel like what
you went through as a kid
kind of gave you empathy for people that
are going through the same things
yeah it is i want to help people you
know i mean so
like nobody should have went through
what i went through i went through a lot
and i'm in and out of jail
um like i said being raped i sold my
cousin one of my guns and he shot me
pointing blank on the side with a
what a blank said that [ __ ] still hurt
but like just playing around like
i don't know it's kind of something like
i'm i'm going to break a foot now so
like it's hard you know i mean i don't
want walking through town with a burger
foot
but no fear no money like nothing you
drink
it sucks i mean i got tattoos on my face
people think i'm gang banging like i
mean whether if i am or not you know i
mean
it don't matter who what i what i
represent or who i represent
because at the end of the day you can't
change somebody for who they are
i mean we're we're earned people you
know i mean so like
at the end of the day i i'm a tattoo
artist you know i mean so i tattoo
so like that's what i need to do is get
my tattoo stuff
and i'm gonna get a place get a job get
a good woman every single nine years so
lego sucks you know i mean so like
but one day i'll make it you know i'm
hoping i keep telling myself that
because uh i keep thinking negative you
know i mean like i just want to kill
myself like i really do like
i just i've been through so much abuse
robbery like i don't know what's right
what's wrong understand so
i gotta tell myself that's not right
what's that's not wrong so like
oh no it's just a lot dude what do you
think set you on that kind of thinking
was it the abuse in your childhood or
something like that well pretty much
like not having a good father because
good fathers are there playing with
their kids and
throwing baseball and taking them out to
eat and
being respectful to their mom treating
their mom like queens you know i mean
like
not blessing them yeah not not sexually
like touching my penis and
their vaginas and you know i mean it's
just it's wrong
you know i mean like it makes that's why
i hurt people because people like that
get deserve to get hurt like pedophiles
deserve to get hurt
like what made you see the people that
are
like turning into pedophiles and rapists
as they are like that
because of how they were brought up
you know i mean so when they're sexually
molested all the time and
when they try to go for somebody for
help it's like they're scared and
they get called a liar you know nobody
believes or knows the truth on certain
people and things don't mean
so it's it's it's messed up
i mean what was the roughest time in
your life
right now
pretty much growing up as a kid and now
i guess because i never lived a homeless
life you know i mean
so this is the first time i've lived
almost life like i'm not gonna say i'm
better than everybody because i'm not
you know i mean
am i tougher than everybody i'm not you
know i'm just myself
i mean but i don't like being marked as
um how you say it a target
you know i mean like all because he's
white all because he's like man
screw the racist [ __ ] like why be racist
like
not everybody's racist you know what i
mean but people are racist they're just
childish you know i mean like
they gotta grow up and see that it's not
all about college
it's i mean you can still like be
different color you know i mean because
i like black and
spanish you know i mean like i like
white too but like
the thing is i mess with everybody you
know i mean so
if you can't be cool with me then i got
nothing to say
i mean i'm not i'm not here to change
anybody's lives if i can change it
then that's a good thing you know what i
mean because then i wish i could help
change myself
so for me to be able to change myself
and change my
lifestyle i mean i need good advice and
positive people in my life
so when you put yourself around a bad
category then
you're just gonna be negative you're
gonna be in and out of jail
missing your families missing your
numbing like your kids
like and kids and family loved ones
don't want that you understand what i'm
saying
so it's rough i mean some people are
just gotta
think before they do something you
understand i'm saying
yeah so it's been
it's been messed up you know i mean i've
had my ribs broke and like this
is they've been they're healed now but
like i've been through a lot of abuse
and i mean
like i don't know
if there's one thing you could have
changed about your childhood what would
it be
um that i wish i had the perfect family
perfect mom well my mom is perfect but
like a perfect dad and like uh
just things perfect you know i mean like
i'm not asking to be handed out i
understand i like to work for things but
like that's what i mean
like oh a better life that's what i want
i mean yeah what's the most important
lesson you've learned
in your life um supporting us
on learning life you've been through a
lot
to be honest it's still i don't know
i can't put myself in the category
because i've been through so much that
uh
the only thing i'm learning is to keep
learning that i'm i'm a loyal dude
i don't beat on women you know i mean
not true i treat them like queens
i treat my homies like friends i don't i
don't steal from friends
like i don't treat people like crap you
know i mean i don't judge people like
i'm a genuine one-of-a-kind guy like
what keeps you on track like that
um because a lot of people in your shoes
would have
would be hustlers and snakes that's
right you're right about that
but uh you gotta keep thinking you know
what i mean like you gotta stop things
tonight it's
it's a start you see the star right here
you gotta stop
think act and review so sometimes you
just gotta
stop and think before you just do
something stupid
or sometimes think you know i mean when
you got a bunch of money and you see
somebody struggling
like here's a dollar and you see
somebody with a kid like here's two
dollars or something get yourself
get your kids something i mean like you
just gotta go and tell people like try
to like uh
you gotta think positive i mean for you
to build a build a do positive thing
positive that's any way you're gonna
grow up in life and i mean you gotta you
gotta stop and think
you know if you don't stop and think
then they're gonna be acting
like a fool you know i'm saying so and i
used to do it too you know i mean
like drive-bys shootings stabbing
robbing people like this just it gets
old after a while and i mean just
i don't care how gangster you think
people are you are like
whatever my cell phone is just at the
end of the day
it's just it's boring it's old you know
i mean like
you don't get things handed to you like
that and i mean so you gotta
i don't know so i gotta learn to i gotta
learn to be a better person you know i
mean
and help people that's how i feel i
think we all do yeah
all right brad well thank you so much
for sharing your story appreciate it i
wish you the best of luck finding your
brother and
straighten your life out oh yeah man
appreciate it thank you man
you